My name is Gary Stevenson
formertrader & people's economist
This is gary's economics, today we're going
to talk about tax and national insurance
OK, so if you've been following the news the
last couple of months you will have seen
that the conservative government has
raised nationalinsurance contributions
that means that as long as you work
for your money your pay packet
is goingto go down at the beginning
of the next tax yearby an extra 1.25%
now what does that mean?
the first thing is we need to explain
veryclearly what national insurance is
Nationalinsurance is a fixed percentage of your
salary which goes to the government as tax.
It's verysimple, people think or like to say that
it's used to pay for your pension or socialcare
but it's not! it's just a tax in many ways
exactly like income tax
a certain percentage comesout your
salary & goes to government's tax
how is it different to income tax and
why is the government chosen to raise
national insurance instead of income tax
okay so there are a few key differences
the first thing is you start paying
national insurance at a lower rate of salary
so you don't pay national insurance
until you make about £9,500 a year
and you don't pay income tax
until about £12,500 a year
so people on very low incomes will
pay national insurance whereas
slightly higherincome before you
need to start paying income tax
the second important thing is income tax is
whatwe call a progressive tax
in the sense that it's designed so that the
higher your income the moremoney you make
a higher percentage that you pay
so you only start paying 20%
on low amounts of income and then on
very high amounts of income you pay 40%
national insurance is designed the opposite
way soyou pay 12% on low incomesand then
when you getto higher incomes you
only pay 2% so it's intentionally designed
National Insurance, so that very rich
people pay a very low percentage.
unlike income tax where very high
income people pay a high percentage
so that's strange, it's a verystrange design
of tax, it's designed specificallyso that
rich people pay less than poor people in
terms of a percentage of their overall income
The third big difference is that national insurance
is designed so that only working people pay it
now if you watched my earlier video
'what is wealth?' you willunderstand
that whilst the vast majority of people in
this country make their money from working
mostvery very rich people and families
don't make themoney from work but
instead own huge amounts ofassets
and get income from those assets
so while you might be working
and making £30,000 a year
somebody who has a wealth of
£1,000,000,000 like Rishi Sunak's family
will make £30,000,000 a year
just from owning so much assets
national insurance does not tax income
from assets it only taxes income from work
A 1.25% rise which is what they voted through
if you make £30,000 a year you'll pay £250 extra
If you are like Rishi Sunak's father-in-law
and you have a £1,000,000,000
you'll make about £30,000,000 a year
andyou'll pay nothing (in tax)
so it's a very interesting tax
high income people pay low percentages
and extremely wealthy people pay nothing
whereas very low income people pay it
and ordinaryworkers pay it
so to be honest it's a pretty bad tax
falls largely on poor & middle income people
totally ignores very very high income people
especially if you're extremely wealthy
and your income comes from wealth
now if you watched my first video 'how the rich
get richer from covid-19' you will have seen that
during covid-19 the rich made a huge amount
of money especially the very rich we have the
data on that now we can see that billionaires
in this country saw their wealth increase by
about 22% so the top 3 billionaires saw their
wealth increase by £20 billion just in Covid
the top 250 had a wealth increase of over
£100billion so why is it that after a crisis
where ordinary people suffered and the rich got
very very rich the government has chosen a tax
which makes high-income people pay a low percent
and makes extremely wealthy people pay nothing
i don't think the answer is very complicated it's
probably because our chancellor is a billionaire
so this guy probably doesn't want to raise taxes
on billionaires um but you know it's not just
the chancellor if you if you look at other senior
politicians like David Cameron like George Osborne
like Nick Clegg like Tony Blair, if we look at
what they've done since they left office generally
they've gone to work for big corporations
and made extremely high salaries so
David Cameron for example went to work for Greensil
which is a company which went bust but he was
making i think over $10 million working there so
if we live in a world where the main politicians
become multi-multi-millionaires or even
are billionaires when they're in office
they are unlikely to raise taxes on
multi-millionaires and billionaires
the end result is they raise taxes on people
making 20 or 30 grand a year ordinary people
now if you watch my video what is wealth you will
see that we already have a system where wealth
inequality is very high, a lot of money transfers
from people who don't have wealth towards the
owners of wealth every single year which means
they get richer and ordinary people get poorer
this is why housing is becoming less affordable
and why the economy is struggling to recover
if we add on top of that system where we raise
taxes on ordinary people and we specifically
exclude multi-millionaires and billionaires this
is going to get worse much quicker and it's going
to affect ordinary families their ability
to get jobs their ability to get houses so
basically it's a corrupt system
we've just come out of a crisis
where lots of people have died many more
people have suffered serious financial hardship
and yet multi-millionaires and billionaires have
seen their wealth increase by an enormous amount
after that when the country needs money
and this money is being raised to pay for
elderly care rather than taxing the billionaires
who made a fortune during the crisis a literal
billionaire chancellor is taxing younow
if we stand by and let this happen then
next time there's a crisis, next time they need
moneywhat do you think they're going to do?
They're gonna do the same thing again they're
gonna protect multi-millionaires and billionaires
because they themselves are multi-millionaires and
billionaires and they're gonna tax you your money
instead of them and their billionaire mates so
i think now is an important time to take a
stand to push back to do whatever you can you
know that means talking to your friends and family
explaining what's happening show them this video
send a letter to your MP telling me
you're not happy about it you know
especially if you have a conservative
MP (who are in power) ask them why are
these guys not taxing billionaires ask them
why they're taxing ordinary people instead
don't just stand by and let it happen, understand
what's happening, push back, tell your friends
tell your family and take a stand because if
ordinary people allow the super rich to taxthem
while they themselves often end up paying
rates of tax: 10%, 5%, even less
then it's going to be a system where ordinary
people progressively lose their houses,
lose their ability to make money and our next
generation isgoing to be poor so yeah fight back
spread this message, share this video, tellyour
friends, tell your family, don't let it happen
housing could be so much more affordable wages
could be so much higher and we could have so
many more options in how we live our lives some
of them put a lot of money into paying economists
and think tanks to tell you that inequality
is important for the economy that is not true